Hello. Welcome to our unit on inheritance. Also known as, what not to do when
you are chased by a bear. So, recall the question we ended the last unit with,
which is what was up with these magic methods? And we saw two of them, init and
str, when they're missing, when we didn't define them in the class. It seemed
like they were still there. That would make them pretty magical. They're not
really that magical. So, let me show you what's going on. So, let me show you
that they're actually there. So, we're going to define a totally empty class. No
attributes, no definitions at all. And I'm going to create an instance of that
class. And we saw that, that instance has an str attribute and it's a method.
And we can invoke that str method and we get the string. Not a very interesting
one, but we do get a string back. And we can see using dir, which is an
operation that takes any object and gives us a list of attributes to find for
that object. That's there's actually a whole bunch of attributes to find for
this empty class already. And we see that these include the str attribute, which
turns it into a string, as well as the init attribute, which initializes it.
What's going on here is what we call inheritance, which is a way to reuse
definitions from other classes when we define new classes. We'll get to
inheritance soon, as well as, the mystery of where these extra magic methods
came from. Before getting to inheritance, I want to cover three other aspects of
Python that you may not have seen before, that we haven't yet covered in this
class. That's format strings, named arguments, and default parameters. If you
already feel comfortable with those things, feel free to skip ahead to where I
start talking about inheritance.